[Musique]
là il ya quelque chose que je comprends
pas qu'est ce que tu as dans la main
une grecque
et pour elle elle est pour qui la
galette par mois
parce que moi je pensais qu'il allait me
le fais à l'est pas pour moi si alors
pourquoi tu la manges et c'est comme ça
tu me laissera un peu
tu peux continuer à aller bien dans un
bel état il a grignoté la jeunesse
tu peux continuer à bouger
[Musique]
bako rien mais quelles sont les banques
qui ont été offerts à la galette elle
est belle et bum stéphane legleye thuram
offrir oui ma tâche de la manger tu
vends les un peu je suis sûr que ses
parents sont des gens tranquilles d'un
bout de l'année à l'autre stéphane du
bien on l'applaudît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je veux c'est qu'est ce que c'est ça la
galette et qui sait qu'elle a compris
c'est ce que j'ai compris c'est une
galette que tu as acheté pour moi
il oui
[Musique]
pour tous les gars c'est sûr
pour moi tous les deux oui ça c'est ma
part
c'est les miettes ma ba
tu veux pas garder ma part de galette
parce que je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais le marchand elle était comme ça
quand tu l'as acheté
il ya alors qu'est ce qui manque qui
sait qu'il a mangé
mois
non c'est pas de galettes scène pour une
pour toi
oh lalala lalala
je veux pas tomber tu proviens
l'intelligent
on met dans l'eau
je ne savais pas moi
qu'est ce qui me fait rire j'ai une
grosse tête et sert également
makarova
moi j'ai un gros vent oui où tu vois que
je ne sois pas quel âge tu as stéphane
facco tu vas l'école oui je sais écrire
non alors qu'est ce que tu fais à
l'école et détient déjà un tas des
frères et des soeurs
après les grandes pas
il est plus grandes toiles nom et avec
qui tu es venu là alors allez papa
hemingway
était albert doit les koster et puis
pépé qui est pélémois decoster qui se
passe mais mes la boïte et mamée margot
it enfants à tata concept aussi
étrange famille bonjour messieurs dames
qu'est-ce qui fait papa comme métier et
là sur arce assez bon et maman travaille
non ah ben si elle veut elle fait la
cuisine le ménage oui tu es sage à
l'école ou des passages ses passages à
qu'est ce que tu fais pour être passage
à bbt dix mois une bêtise que tu as fais
rien je dis pas parce que la mécène
béquilles
ok moi j'aime manger la galette c'est
moi qui ai mangé la galette on va
dégonfler comme août
c'est moi qui ai mangé les collèges oui
qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras grand stéphane voulez
quoi
rouler qu'est ce que c'est un poulet il
polit
les meilleures couleurs
bref intervalle contravention eh bien
monsieur le poulet
patriotes
et salles comme agitateur coupe oui non
c'est ce qu'on prend tout qu'est ce que
tu chantes ces femmes est-ce que tu
puisses la mission
aller jusqu'à ce qu'ils puissent y aura
ici on peut me dire sa chanson du
hérisson la chanson d'une réduction qui
pique allez-y la hausse testing est elle
sans
son
au stade de ligue 1
ils sont
animés se tassant son
terrain sous tutelle du futur tout cas
respect à ce mondial c'est papa papa pas
parce que pas très critiquée ce taux est
son but est de piquet
moi j'y vois pas papa malick ba a suivi
des espèces de pick up f 150
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens c'est non t'aimes pas les femmes
n'ont pas raison à l'est
[Musique]